[Musique]
au lendemain de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes la
première ministre Elisabeth borne s'est
rendue à la maison Calypso structure de
prise en charge des femmes victimes de
violence de plaisir accompagnée de
François brode ministre de la santé et
de la prévention et de la ministre
délégué chargé notamment de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes Isabelle
longvyrum et il y a notamment présenté
le plan égalité de 1027 parmi les
actions le déploiement d'une maison des
femmes dans chaque département ou encore
le remboursement par la Sécurité sociale
des protections périodiques
réutilisables pour les femmes de moins
de 25 ans le spectre d'une pénurie de
carburant inquiète les automobilistes la
grève a été reconduite sur tous les
sites de Total énergie ce matin la
production n'est pas bloquée mais plus
aucun carburant ne sort s'il faudrait
des jours voir des semaines avant que
les réserves des 200 dépots de carburant
répartis sur les territoires français ne
puissent plus approvisionner les
stations services certaines sont tout de
même déjà en rupture partielle ou totale
vous pouvez suivre la situation en temps
réel sur le site qui s'affiche dans la
barre d'infos
depuis décembre le bar de la salle de
spectacle du prisme à Élancourt a fait
peau neuve 55000 euros auront été
nécessaires à la rénovation de ce lieu
culturel 50 ninois durant les trois mois
de travaux musique jazz en live les
soirs de spectacle les petites
restauration sur place sont proposées ou
vers au public en janvier 2023 cet
espace modernisé sera inauguré ce soir
sous le nom de la ruche l'idée c'était
de faire quelque chose qui soit
industriel chic qui soit un peu élégant
à l'image du prisme c'est-à-dire quelque
chose de d'un peu haut de gamme et puis
effectivement que que notre public
puisse y retrouver on a tout refait la
partie menuiserie du bar un petit coin
louche pour que ça soit un peu un peu
sympathique quand on vit entre amis
c'est un lieu qui les retrouve c'est un
lieu qu'il connaisse mais qui là il le
connaissent mais qui a été qui a été
ravivé et je vois pour avoir discuté
aussi avec eux je vois leur émotion
quand on en parle le marché de
Rambouillet et de nouveau en lice pour
devenir le plus beau marché de France
TF1 a lancé cette semaine la sixième
édition de son concours votre plus beau
marché et celui de Rambouillet figure
parmi les 8 candidats franciliens si
vous souhaitez le soutenir rendez-vous
sur le site de TF1 et vous pour voter et
enfin pour rappel la phase d'inscription
des vœux sur parcoursup se termine ce
soir à 23h59 après cette date il ne sera
plus possible de rajouter de nouveaux
vœux sur la plateforme à partir de
demain et jusqu'au 6 avril ce sera la
phase de confirmation pour cela il
faudra compléter les dossiers avec
notamment des lettres de motivation les
pièces seront directement envoyées aux
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
[Musique]